aircraft Hakimi is a well-known football
player making a million pounds a month
he got married and his wife recently
divorced him and demanded to have half
of his money and it turned out that he
didn't actually have any money eighty
percent of his income and a hundred
percent of his assets and his wealth
were in his mama's name so when his wife
tried to divorce him and take half of
his money it turned out actually he
didn't have anything and apparently
she's now having to give him money
because she's got a couple of smaller
assets this story completely broke the
internet and everybody is crowning him
as a hero he might have just completely
changed the game
all that story and within 10 seconds of
just looking at the headline of the
story and what had happened I look at
that football player and I know that he
is financially illiterate what he did
was not smart what he did was not cool
it was actually stupid selfishly
speaking it was a stupid Financial move
and it might have been the short term
look like it's paid off for him really
well but the reason I'm doing this video
is because I coach a lot of football
players I coach a lot of people that
make similar money to what he's making
Premier League football players and I
just have this horrible feeling that
everybody's gonna go that's a brilliant
move and they're going to stop putting
all of their wealth into their parents
name let me tell you why it's completely
stupid number one if you put all your
money in your mom's name because you
don't trust your own judgment of who you
could potentially marry and you're
worried that the person that you choose
to marry might come after you and take
half your money so instead you put the
money in your mom's name
the same thing could happen to your mom
your mom I don't know if his mom's
single married to his dad I don't know
what the story is if her and the dad
split up and the mom would be married
Anything could happen then the money is
just as unprotected so what he's really
saying is he's not being cool by putting
his mom's name he's really admitting
that he's a complete idiot who lacks
judgment and he's saying I don't trust
you I'll marry but Mom I trust your
judgment much more that's not cool
that's stupid unless admitting that
you're stupid so that's the first reason
that I think he's done because his mom
could get divorced his mom could marry a
complete learning especially if his
mom's got loads and loads and loads of
money it's putting his mom at risk it's
advocating the responsibility of wealth
rather than being responsible the second
reason is because his mom will probably
die a long time before he dies if things
happen the natural way and when his mom
dies firstly
the money unless she's got a will where
she specifically says all the money is
going to go to him what will happen is
the money will be spit up amongst him
and his siblings he's given all his
money to his mom because he's so scared
of it going to his wife but actually
he's probably gonna get a split up
amongst his siblings now he might say I
don't mind that that's okay because
they're my siblings but here's another
thing he's really worried about giving
half his money to his ex-wife when his
mom dies he won't just split the money
with his siblings his mom will die he'll
have to pay
inheritance tax on his own money so if
his mom's got 20 mil and he's really
worried him having the 20 million in
case his wife tries to take half well
he's going to end up giving the
government half anyway inheritance tax
is 40 so if he's got 10 million or 20
million he's left to give almost half of
that to the government so his fear of
choosing the wrong partner and having to
give half the money to his ex-wife well
instead he's just going to end up giving
half the money to the government instead
of going from oh I've got a chance that
she might leave me and take off my money
he's just saying no now I'm guaranteed
to give half of it to the government so
it doesn't make any sense at all so
every time I've ever seen this happen
and I coach a lot of football players
and I often see a lot of wealthy young
people do this they'll just go oh I
can't manage the money and I I'm not
responsible enough and I might marry a
lunatic I'm going to give it to their
mom give it to their dad as if that's
going going to protect their situation
but it doesn't if we look through
history I mean I've recently been
watching the movies at the cinema you
know the Elvis movie and Whitney Houston
and all these famous young people that
made tens and tens of millions of pounds
and they all do the same thing they all
just completely delegate the
responsibility to their family and often
they get screwed I just watched the
Whitney Houston movie and she was doing
the same thing she was just pushing it
to her dad my daddy will look after me
my dad I'll just give to my dad her dad
screwed her so his mum could screw up
his mum has complete power over him now
now he's like a little boy mommy could
have some pocket money please because
he's worried about who he can trust a
lot of these very wealthy young people
that make a lot of money through a skill
an absolutely brilliant Talent of
singing or football playing they end up
absolutely skint and bankrupt because
instead of being responsible and
learning how to protect himself and
learning properly how to manage money
they just pass it to their mom to their
dads and end up giving loads of money to
the government on heritage tax end up
having their own family screw them or
end up having their family end up having
a divorce choosing the wrong spouse and
if they lose it anyway so it's not cool
what he did it's not smart it shouldn't
be applauded what would be much cooler
would be if he had had a really strong
solid prenuptial agreement or if he had
an overseas trust set up where he was
putting the money over into a trust that
was completely protected maybe no one
even knew about it well what would be
really cool which I would applaud would
be if he just took responsibility and I
only had to manage his money but if he
took responsibility on how to marry the
right person now I'd never blame anybody
for divorce it's sadly something that
can happen to anybody but when I got
married I was dating my wife Amanda we
had no mutual friends and I kept my
portfolio secret this was nine years ago
now before I was well known on YouTube I
kept my portfolio secret we got to know
each other as people not for what I had
and before I asked her to marry me I
thought I need to tell her at some point
about my finances rather than telling
her about my finances and saying hey
I've been keeping it secret this is how
rich I am I said to her hey I need to
tell about my finances she said yeah I
said I've actually not been 100 honest
I've got a million pounds
worth of debt
which was true because if you added up
my mortgages at the time it was over a
million pounds and I sat and waited for
her reaction and she said you know what
she said I love you we can get through
this maybe I need to get some overtime
some extra hours
but but it's okay thank you for being
honest with me I thought I know that
she's the one I then asked her to marry
me she said yes told her the other side
said I have got a million pounds of debt
but I've got a lot more net than debt
and also I've got these properties which
I have got mortgages on but they also
give us x amount of monthly passive
income so you know you're gonna get
married and if you don't if you don't
want you don't have to work again and
she said
oh that's good isn't it like yeah it's
really good we got married nine years
ago been happily married we've got three
kids best thing that ever happened to me
so putting your money in your parents
name because you're scared that you
can't look after it should not be
applauded what should be applauded is
financial responsibility and
responsibility of your life your wealth
your finances and then look after as
many people as you can help as many
people as you can but be responsible
hope you enjoyed the video let me know
your thoughts in the comments see you
next time
[Music]
thank you